you kind of uh left
the the movie making business
at an interesting time perhaps you saw
the changes
um
there's been a lot of excitement with
netflix with tv so the
the role of film in society has changed
so
what do you think is the future of
movies versus tv like if you were as a
business person as a creator as a
consumer
as a technologist
are thinking about the next 10 20 years
what do you think is going to be the
the godfather the great
pieces that move us as a society in the
next 10 20 years this is going to be tv
is it going to be movie is it going to
be uh tick tock
uh clips
what is it
well
so i i and i think the other category
that i would add to that that will be
the next great medium
is truly immersive virtual reality
in which
new storytellers will emerge
especially when you can go into vr
and there's enough computing power to
sustain it
and to allow it to be social and you
know for you to have different paths to
go down
that'll be i think the next realm of
what storytelling and experience will
will look like so do you think uh video
game kind of world or is it more movies
or is it more
social network or is it all of it kind
of
blending reality and gaming and movies
yeah i thought uh if you saw ready
player one which i love the book and and
the movie was cool too
but
you know that that's one version of it
right where you go in
now everybody's talking about the
metaverse and all that but you go into a
world that's fully rendered
as yourself and you interact with that
world the other side of it is to go in
somewhere between being a passive
observer but being able to move around
your point of view and experiences which
i think is interesting
and then i think another another
adventure so to speak i could think of
is
a blend of video games so there's a
mission right there's a there's
obstacles there's everything and you
move through it but it's immersive and
it tells a story at the same time and
that's why i think
you're going to see
new amazing storytellers
that we don't know yet
that understand how to innovate and how
to make you feel something in in that
environment
um
into your earlier point
you know i
saw probably around 2015
when netflix decided to be bold put out
house of cards put out all the episodes
leave you in charge of the pace at which
you would view them
uh which i thought was was great
that was a gutsy move yes it was and i
can't tell you around hollywood anybody
that says that everybody thought it was
a great idea is not being truthful
because
everybody i talked to said this is
they're idiots right they're what do
they know about movie making and tv
and
what i saw happening
was if you look at what netflix pulled
off and they realized that there isn't
really a moat around the studios
you really could make stuff um
and really good stuff and so they
started to create their own content
that pulled in
amazon which pulled in google through
youtube and and then you had hulu then
you had
disney deciding that they're going to
have disney plus and the next thing you
know
you have some of the the biggest
companies with the largest balance
sheets on the planet
uh being in the creative business that's
you know if you're an independent that's
that's bringing a a knife to a gunfight
to be sure
and so
you know i thought that was interesting
the other thing that it used to be that
movies were where the big things
happened and television was sort of
it was small screen different experience
and you had something like game of
thrones come out which was not only on
the same
epic level visually and storytelling
wise but had the budget to be able to do
it
and now
i think you're you're seeing um
you're seeing uh
all kinds of
different storytelling taking place
and i also like that it's you're not
pigeonholed into
a time like you got two hours to tell
the story you can do a three-part
mini-series a five-part mini-series you
can do television that's
you know all kinds of different format
now that i think is uh
allows creators to do a lot more
interesting things
it is also interesting to consider the
role of companies that enable that like
the capital that enables that you know
without netflix you wouldn't an hbo you
wouldn't have
um some of these epic shows and so for
if we're thinking about the virtual
reality world that you're talking about
it's interesting to consider who will
enable that you know now like you said
facebook is talking about meta and
metaverse
but it's unclear that just having money
is enough
netflix did a lot of really
revolutionary stuff there's a you know
amazon has money there's a lot of
companies have money that don't quite do
as good of a job yet
at enabling creators of
um
creating revolutionary new content that
changes the the whole industry and
that's probably going to be the case
with virtual reality there there is a
lot of money needed to enable
experiences like in terms of compute
infrastructure
there needs to be a huge amount of money
there but you also need to somehow give
freedom to creators to have fun
to do their best work and at the same
time
like
provide the
the perfect amount of constraints all of
that together like however netflix makes
it happen they do a pretty good job
because it's a very constrained platform
but yet all the creators i've ever
talked to comedians and so on that work
with netflix are really happy because
they feel free
to create their work yeah and i i think
a lot of times
you know companies are a letterhead but
it boils down to the people yeah and i
think um
i've known ted sarandos a long time who
who ran the studio at netflix and now
took over for reed
running the company but ted
very smart talented guy and understood
early how to cultivate talent and
relationships with talent which is
important when you're dealing with
creative people
uh their motivations and their goals are
not always the same right they're not
always capitalistic
right and so in terms of being able to
communicate
with creative people uh that are not
always a to b to c is is a talent and so
i think they they did a great job ted
did a great job with that early
um
you know but i i think that you're gonna
see
different formats i i don't think
i mean going to a theater
to see a massive movie
on that screen in that format i is a
fundamentally different experience yeah
and i think you're gonna find movies uh
you know my old shop legendary just put
out dune which i thought was
phenomenal
um i uh you know we when we secured the
rights to dune years ago
it was
i was over the moon because it's i love
the book i love the the entire world
um that uh
that is dune
and that's a movie that i think you see
on the the big screen i think uh
when avatar two comes out i want to see
that
on a big screen but i think you're going
to see
a ton of content is obviously being
produced and it's not all going to go to
a theater going experience so you're
going to see
i think different versions of this over
the next five to 10 years
you